[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale elle nous sommes le jeudi 3 mars
voici les titres lui jours après
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
les mobilisations se poursuivre dans les
yvelines solidarité collecte hébergement
se met en place face à la crise un
sommet européen se tiendra à versailles
les 10 et 11 mars prochains
également dans ce journal le témoignage
d'une yvelinoise bloqué à moscou et puis
jean pierre pernaut est décédé hier
mercredi 2 mars à l'âge de 71 ans
présentateur du journal de 13 heures de
tf1 pendant trente trois ans le
journaliste a succombé des suites d'un
cancer des poumons elle nous sommes
allés à la rencontre des douves siennois
comme une roue et résider et puis le
contrat d'engagement jeunes un nouveau
dispositif lancé par le gouvernement
avec pôle emploi mardi qu'il s'adresse
aux jeunes de moins de 26 ans sans
emploi et sans formation un
accompagnement personnalisé qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du plan
gouvernemental
un jeune une solution elle les détails
dans cette édition et puis nous
parlerons également de la collecte
nationale des restos du coeur qui aura
lieu ce week-end également le paris nice
la 80e édition sera au départ des
yvelines ce dimanche et puis le salon de
l'agriculture nous ferons un retour sur
le week end
[Musique]
et tout d'abord c'est une nouvelle étape
dans l'allègement des mesures sanitaires
jean castex était l'invitée du journal
de 13 heures de tf1 ce jeudi à 3 mars le
premier ministre a annoncé
officiellement la fin du pass vaccinale
et puis la fin du port du masque en
intérieur sauf bien sûr dans le cadre
des transports collectifs et des mesures
qui prendront effet le 14 mars prochain
le pass vaccinale devraient cependant
rester en vigueur dont les
établissements de santé
et puis également autres allocutions
cette fois-ci d'emmanuel macron face à
la guerre en ukraine il s'est exprimé ce
mercredi 2 mars à 20 heures après avoir
réaffirmé le soutien de la france envers
l'ukraine le président de la république
a annoncé l la tenue d'un sommet
européen à versailles ce sera les 10 et
11 mars prochains il réunira les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement européens
si le rendez vous était déjà prévu dans
le cadre de la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne
à l'ordre du jour lui a changé au
programme bien sûr le conflit ukrainien
selon emmanuel macron l'europe a besoin
à d'un nouveau modèle économique est
fondé sur l'indépendance et le progrès
il souhaite défendre une stratégie
d'indépendance énergétique européenne
pour ne plus dépendre notamment du gaz
russe par exemple également jeu ce titre
notre défense européenne doit franchir
une nouvelle étape fin de citation le
président de la république a également
profité de cette allocution pour
informer lé français sur l'impact
économique de ce conflit notamment
l'augmentation à des prix il a annoncé
mettre en place un plan de résilience
économique et social pour les prochains
jours
et puis toujours dans le cadre du
conflit en réponse à l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie les vingt sept
pays de l'union européenne ont décidé le
dimanche 27 février de fermer l'espace
aérien européen aux avions et compagnie
aérienne russe suite à cette décision le
ministère des affaires étrangères a
recommandé aux français en russie de
quitter sans délai le pays et c'est le
cas notamment de lola 22 ans qui est
actuellement à moscou elle était bloquée
est là bas elle vit chez ses parents aux
essarts-le-roi alors comment se sont ils
organisés pour la faire revenir l
nicolas adam dry est allé à leur
rencontre regardée
avec sa fille actuellement à moscou
claire montagne on n'est pas sereine ces
derniers jours avec le début de la
guerre sa fille lola de 22 ans va
revenir chez elle aux essarts-le-roi
lady réservé dimanche 27 février en
passant par la finlande ne sont plus
valables l'espace aérien européen a été
fermé aux avions et compagnie aérienne
russe et vol
enfin fondent comme neige au soleil que
le temps d'un clic il est plus dispo
externe donc ça devient un peu un peu
tendu quand même et puis on a fini on
comprend que le prochain qu'on trouve il
faut pas réfléchir
plus de deux minutes et donc on a trouvé
un vol pour ankara moscou ankara puis
ankara bové voilà le trajet que va
emprunter lola
malgré une situation habituelle dans la
capitale russe la vie pour les étrangers
devient compliqué
tu as fait de cash
d'accord
d'accord cette jeune étudiante
yvelinoise est parti à moscou le samedi
19 février un séjour de trois semaines
pour prendre des cours intensifs de
langue russe j'en ai parlé autour de moi
j'avais beaucoup les enfants j'écoute la
radio et en fait quand je suis parti
très peu de gens pensaient que ça être
qu'à la dre à ce point et comme ce qui
était importante pour moi parce que j'en
aurai besoin probablement pour mon
cursus académique et professionnelle du
côté des essarts le roi chez la famille
montagnon la sérénité devrait revenir
l'arrivée de lola à beauvais est prévue
le vendredi 4 mars en fin d'après midi
et puis en soutien à l'ukraine
l'association humanitaire à la gerbe
peut installer avec vie a fait partir
aujourd'hui un camion direction la
roumanie le semi remorque a été chargé
de 10 tonnes de matériel vêtements
chaussures mais aussi l des fournitures
médicales des produits d'hygiène et de
l'alimentation de longue durée depuis sa
création en 1988 l'association envoie
régulièrement des convois vers l'est de
l'europe en ukraine le contact avait été
établi avec les associations locales
depuis 2009 700 tonnes de matériel ont
pu être envoyés sur place en 13 ans en
moyenne un camion part à toutes les
trois semaines la gerbe espère augmenter
sa cadence à un départ par semaine les
propos recueillis par grégory canale
l'idée c'est avec avec ce conflit là
c'est comment on intensifie
d'une part surtout donc les pays
limitrophes puisque la tous nos
partenaires sont aussi très mobilisé
pour l'accueil des réfugiés
et puis sur l'ukraine donc en amenant le
semi-remorque le plus près de la
frontière et après ça paraît en petites
camionnettes celui que vous voyez
derrière moi va vers la roumanie parce
que pour l'instant c'est le contact
solide et rapide que l'on a puisque on a
nos correspondants qui sont là-bas
brasov et plus est dans la centre de la
roumanie qui se mobilisent pour à la
fois accueillir des réfugiés mais aussi
envoyer du matériel vers la frontière
entre l'ukraine et la roumanie puisqu'on
sait qu'il ya un afflux constant en ce
moment envoyé du matériel ou même se
déplacer sur place et pour aider
l'association de collecte en ligne est
rouverte quinze mille euros ont déjà pu
être récoltés vous pouvez aussi bien sûr
donner du matériel toutes les
informations sur le site doullens de
l'association pardon humanitaire la
gerbe
[Musique]
et je vous en parlais en titre le
contrat d'engagement jeunesse et un
nouveau dispositif lancé par le
gouvernement avec pôle emploi mardi il
s'inscrit dans le cadre du plan
gouvernemental un jeune une solution et
on en parle avec vous à chemy lamari
bonsoir vous êtes noir vous êtes
directeur territorial délégué pôle
emploi yvelines alors c'est un
accompagnement qui s'adresse aux jeunes
de moins de 26 ans donc sans emploi et
sans formation
pourquoi aujourd'hui ce dispositif et
quels sont les objectifs finalement
le dispositif le contrat d'engagement
jeunes s'inscrit comme vous le dites
dans les actions d'un jeune une solution
qu'on a démarré déjà depuis près de deux
ans maintenant le contrat s'adresse à
des jeunes de moins de 26 ans qui ont
beaucoup plus de difficultés que les
autres à s'insérer dans le marché du
travail et ils n'ont ni formation ni
sang ni en formation ni en emploi
l'objectif de ce dispositif c'est de
passer de la signature aujourd'hui d'un
contrat d'engagement jeunes avec pôle
emploi ou avec la mission locale puisque
les missions locales aux six mètres
mettre ce dispositif en oeuvre c'est de
passer d'un contrat l'engagement jeunes
un contrat de travail tout court c'est
l'objectif
initial est unique pour ce dispositif
donc c'est un accompagnement
personnalisé sur plusieurs mois comment
ça marche concrètement au fait
concrètement à un jeune et son
conseiller s'engage à construire un
projet un parcours une
avec une programmation d'un certain
nombre d'actions et d'activités c'est
entre 15 et 20 heures d'activités par
semaine l'objectif c'est de travailler
sur le projet du jeune comment comment
se mettre en en main en ordre de marche
pour pouvoir trouver un emploi est signé
un contrat de travail ça peut prendre
plusieurs formes ça peut être un travail
sur sûr c'est son projet professionnel
c'est ses orientations professionnelles
ça peut être aussi comme vous le savez
grande sait tous c'est que l'accès aux
entreprises ne serait ce que pour une
découverte de métiers ou une immersion
professionnel c'est assez difficile même
si c'est très important dans le cadre
d'un projet professionnel
le conseiller son s'engage à la
réalisation de ces de ces démarches là
avec son avec sont demandeurs d'emploi
est de faciliter l'accès à l'entreprise
nous avons d'ores et déjà travaillé avec
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui sont
déjà prêtes et qui s'engage à accueillir
ces jeunes rang pour pour une découverte
des métiers notamment les métiers en
tension sur lesquels on a énormément
d'offres aujourd'hui est donc
globalement comment ça va se déployer
dans les yvelines est ce que toutes les
agences oppose impôts avons proposé ce
contrat par exemple
aujourd'hui toutes les agences de tous
les onze agences de des yvelines en déjà
démarré depuis le 1er mars les premiers
accompagnement les premières signatures
de contrats d'engagement au fait dans
chaque agence nous content un conseiller
à trois conseillers qui sont dédiés à
cette activité ils ont déjà commencé à
propos disant surtout toute la partie
tout le mois de février nous avons
commencé à proposer
aux jeunes des yvelines au lieu de 1200
jeunes ont été contactés après à qui on
a proposé déjà le contrat d'engagement
jeunes nous avons à ce matin nous
comptabilisons 542 jeunes qui ont déjà
adhéré au dispositif et qui vont prendre
part à cette à cet accompagnement est
justement vous parlez de deux chiffres
peut-être parce qu'on peut faire un
point sur le chômage des jeunes
justement dans le département
aujourd'hui le le show mais
on
vous a perdu
est-ce que vous m'entendez
sur le le département à un chômage le
chômage des jeunes après à brax alors
elle assure sur une année alors
autant autour de 10% de deux jeunes qui
sont inscrits à pôle emploi néanmoins
nous avons connu un certain nombre de
deux
les mandats des jeunes dans le cadre
d'un jeune une solution qui ont retrouvé
soit des formations soit un retour à
l'emploi aujourd'hui sur le dernier
trimestre 2000 2020 2021 nous
comptabilisons
9300 jeunes inscrits en recherche
d'emploi sans emploi une formation donc
une baisse de 9% rien que sur le dernier
trimestre 2004 2000 2021 est ce que ce
sont des chiffres plutôt encourageants
ou est-ce qu'au contraire et celle
inverse effectivement nous avons en fait
le nombre de jeunes qui ont quitté pôle
emploi et puis le chômage est nettement
supérieure sur les deux les trois
premiers mois sur le département même
s'il ne comptabilisant une
baisse face avait avec avec un rythme
qui est moindre sur sur le dernier
trimestre néanmoins une comptabilisant
sur toute l'année une baisse de 13 % de
chômeurs jeunes juste deux éléments que
je voudrais partager avec vous faites la
crise
la reprise économique est là aujourd'hui
les offres d'emploi sens là nous avons
récoltés sur les rien que sur les huit
premières semaines de 2022 plus de 840
offres d'emploi
quand on a récolté sur la même période
sur 2021 que 400 450 deux offres et
avant crise 642 offres d'emploi donc
nous comptabilisons aujourd'hui plus de
28% d'offre supérieure à d'avant crise
dont vous voyez le
le
offres d'emploi est là et ça profite
effectivement aux jeunes aux jeunes de
jilin donc l'offre d'emploi et la merci
beaucoup et je suis là marie d'avoir été
avec nous le rappelle vous êtes le
directeur territorial délégué pour pôle
emploi evelyne
[Musique]
je vous le disais en titre à la
disparition de jean pierre pernaut
journaliste et présentateur préféré des
français il habitait les yvelines à
louveciennes commune est de 7000
habitants qu'il considérait comme son
havre de paix et où il aimait se
promener entre les journaux télévisés
justement un autre journaliste michael
et demi d'euros et florian se sont
rendus sur place donc j'appelle ma
campagne parce que voilà ça sent l'herbe
ça il ya des arbres et on voit là les
saisons évolué voici comment jean pierre
pernaut nous avait décrit l'ancien en
2010 est une commune où le présentateur
phare de tf1 vécu pendant plusieurs
dizaines d'années ce jeudi 3 mars les
habitants sont encore sous le choc et se
souviennent de l'homme qu'ils ont
côtoyés régulièrement dans les rues
c'était quelqu'un qui était un très
grand professionnel
mais en même temps qu'il n'était pas un
people c'est à dire qu' il pouvait être
tout à fait lui-même naturel à aller
faire ses courses je le croisais dans
au supermarché salut jean pierre on
discutait être fait il était comme
monsieur tout le monde sauf que
effectivement c'était quelqu'un tue tout
le monde ici dans cette ville de 7000
habitants jean-pierre pernaut avait ses
petites habitudes il venait notamment
une à deux fois par semaine dans ce
commerce pour faire ses courses
c'est une personne normale pour moi en
parallèle le journaliste n'hésitez pas à
s'impliquer dans la vie locale de lucian
et notamment dans les comités de
quartier j'en garde le souvenir d'une
personne assez volontaire et puis qui
était très attaché au village d'ailleurs
ils montraient tous les tous les 13
heures sur sur tf1 ou avec son tour de
france des villages et puis des des
éléments insolites de ces villages donc
on peut dire qu'on partage est justement
cet amour des villages ses amours du
patrimoine etc la région je pense pour
laquelle il était venu s'installer à
louveciennes depuis pas mal d'années
certains habitants tentent désormais la
date et le lieu des obsèques de jean
pierre pernaut pour rendre un dernier
hommage à ce look chinois pas comme les
autres
et dans un communiqué a publié ce jour
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes rend hommage à jean
pierre pernaut le présentateur du
journal pendant trente trois ans du
journal de tf1 le 13 heures et je cite
un journaliste profondément impliqué
dans le quotidien des téléspectateurs et
amoureux de la france des régions qui
aura que su comme aucun autre écouter et
donner la parole aux français
et justement pour continuer sur le sujet
nous avons avec nos patrice carmouze
bonsoir bonsoir directeur de
l'information donc gtv 78 patrice vous
vous avez bien connu jean pierre pernaut
puisque vous aviez travaillé avec lui
notamment sur l'émission combien ça
coûte qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti à
l'annoncé de sa mort
était ce parce que je me dis qu'au fond
même si j'ai soulevé par des groupes qui
était
dans le coma depuis quelques jours et
que la fin était irrémédiable mais
pas
il est mort en même temps presque que ce
journal de 13 heures auquel il tenait
tant qu'il avait abandonnée peut-être
avec un point contre coeur ils n'auront
pas su
profiter de de cette retraite même si
c'était si beau qu'il préférait de la
langue française il enfin il aurait pu
quand même
rester auprès de sa famille qu'il
adorait jouer au golf il dit même
beaucoup et c'est vrai que le rapport
profiter de ces moments là mais qu'est
ce que vous allez retenir alors de
l'homme du présentateur du journaliste
jean pierre pernaut d'abord c'était
quelqu'un de 2 francs de loyal de direct
qui pouvait avoir derrière des colères
aller les couloirs tf1 ce
quelques-unes de ses colères homériques
parce que c'était quelqu'un d'exigeant
vis-à-vis évite la vidéo mais c'était
quelqu'un qui était dans la vie comme à
l'écran communauté dont la fille que
vous bien de les démouler le bonne
bouffe les plaisirs simples pour
quelqu'un qui tu es voilà c'était même à
l'étranger jean peut-être une petite
anecdote qui donnent vie
aux familles qui permet de comprendre je
le suis combien ça coûte cette émission
j'avais prévu des sujets le politique
ça l'enchanté pas aux faux ce qui
m'intéressait de vis et ne convient 17
de prendre des vacances combien coûte
d'acheter qu'est ce qu'on fait si on
gagne au loto
qu'ils ont adressé au fond c'était
l'avis des français il avait
probablement raison
finalement il a il avait cependant
était de découper une écoute des autres
et dès que les autres peuples nous
devons prendre quelque chose je pensais
ça
on peut toujours apprendre des autres
pour peu qu'on les conteneurs avec avec
sympathie insee fréquement gare aux faux
les récentes les français sont à la mode
n'est pas une émission petit on fait pas
intervenir le français lambda
après la crise dit j'y ai joué c'est le
grand débat pour dire qu'on écoute des
français va peut-être qu'il a montré
cette voie avec le talent le talent de
l'écouté et de la curiosité des autres
et on a fait sans doute un des jeux
préférés des français sait pas
exactement avec la proximité du
journaliste merci beaucoup patrice
carmouze d'avoir été avec nous pour cet
hommage je le rappelle vous êtes
directeur de l'information chez tv 78
bien sûr toutes nos pensées se tournent
vers la famille et l'entourage de jean
pierre pernaut
[Musique]
et dans le reste de l'actualité c'est un
rendez vous annuel très important pour
les bénévoles et surtout les
bénéficiaires des restos du coeur la
collecte nationale elle est organisée du
4 au 6 mars et elle permet de compléter
les sources d'approvisionnement pour
notamment offrir une alimentation plus
diversifiée est les équipes des restos
daisy been seront présents de dans 73
petites moyennes et grandes surfaces du
département
la collecte nationale va nous permettre
d'assurer la distribution je dirais
dassin d'un certain nombre de produits
ans à des concerts là des féculents des
choses comme ça sur la campagne d'été
qui va commencer
début avril la situation ne va pas et y
entrent dans les mois qui vont venir
d'une part parle ce que nos questions
par rapport à ce que nous connaissons
habituellement en france mais par contre
il ya aussi le problème qui va être
directement liées elles créent dans la
déjà des personnes qui arrivent les
propos recueillis par nicolas landry
avec mélanie poquet l'an dernier 180
tonnes de produits avaient été récoltés
et pour connaître les magasins
partenaires de cette édition n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site de
l'association et plus que trois jours
pour se rendre au salon de l'agriculture
le second territoire agricole d'île de
france les producteurs et binoy sont au
rendez-vous de cette 58e édition miel
caramel 20 cookies yaourt on trouve de
tout dans notre département mathilde
franco est allé rencontrer les
producteurs y blinois c'était au salon
de l'agriculture regarder les allées se
remplissent peu à peu dégustation de bon
matin ou découverte des animaux de la
ferme petits et grands sont contents de
revenir pour la 58e édition du salon de
l'agriculture
après deux ans de fermeture à cause du
coc vide 19 au pavillon 3 du côté de la
région ile de france les gourmands se
retrouvent pour goûter du miel aussi que
le miel soit pas seulement un produit de
consommation j'ai mal à la gorge et je
prends du mieux c'est aussi un plaisir
qu'on se donne à déguster du miel qui
reçoit nature avec du fromage avec de la
viande hic cette façon des yaourts sont
mes yaourts au lait entier de pour
coller de vaches de de notre ferme parce
que nous sommes éleveurs producteurs et
transformateurs directement à la ferme
ou encore des cookies le best seller
chez pierre et insee le 3 chocolats donc
chocolat blanc chocolat noir chocolat au
lait sont des chocolats en provenance de
cacao barry qui sont faire des courbes
dans les yvelines pendant ce temps ça
s'active au pavillon 1 au niveau du
grand ring 44 jeunes de 16 à 24 ans
s'affrontent pour tenter de devenir le
meilleur jeune berger de france manon
batista et lauriane conseil élèves en
bts production animale à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet représenter
l'île de france c'est plus compliqué que
les autres cas de sélection parce qu'on
est avec des jeunes
des personnes qui sont dedans et qui
sont eux aussi fort que nous et
passionné donc c'est plus compliqué mais
on va faire sa place un concours qui
constitue une superbe opportunité pour
ces deux jeunes femmes de 20 ans ça leur
permet d'échanger avec d'autres jeunes
d'autres établissements d'autres régions
aussi de france et de rencontrer des
professionnels qui sont tous ultra
bienveillant qui leur donne qu'un
conseil donc ça c'est bien pour à la
sécu arrivé seul salon franchement c'est
c'est juste super et enfin je le
souhaite à tout le monde j'avais un peu
de hantise mais on voit que les gens
sont tous se stresser aussi et du coup
on se sent bien au centre et des noms
c'est celle et c'est génial fin de
journée les épreuves sont terminés et
les résultats tombent manon et la 21e
meilleur jeune bergère de france et
lauriane arrive en 35e position
une journée mémorable pour les deux
jeunes femmes et si vous ne vous êtes
pas encore rendus au salon de
l'agriculture où vous avez encore le
temps il se poursuit jusqu'au 6 mars
et puis pour terminer ce journal du
sport et puis c'est le début d'un grand
événement sportif ce week end pour la
13e année consécutive le paris-nice
s'élancera des yvelines départ de la
course cycliste ce dimanche 6 mars pour
la première étape pour une boucle de 160
kilomètres à mantes la ville le
lendemain c'est de la commune
d'auffargis dans le sud des yvelines que
partiront les coureurs direction orléans
pour une deuxième étape de 160 km a
également alors recevoir un tel
événement forcément c'est une fierté
pour les deux villes on écoute les deux
maires au micro de michael et demi
d'euros avec grigoriy canale
on a pu avoir cette cette merveilleuse
nouvelle de pouvoir être vil francs
seulement l'étape également donc de
départ évidemment certains mettront en
lumière notre notre commune on est bien
sûr très heureux c'est la première fois
qu'il y à un départ d'étape de paille 10
à mon avis ça va faire de l'animation un
village qui est déjà très animée mais ça
va engager aussi tous nos bénévoles qui
sont là toujours présents jusque là
c'est quand même une belle organisation
doit être bien aidé par esso mais c'est
quand même une grosse organisation pour
un petit village comme le nôtre et pour
célébrer le passage de la course au
soleil le département des yvelines
organise un village d'animations à
mantes-la-ville ce sera à dès le samedi
à 5 mars à la veille du grand départ au
programme des animations initiations au
bmx vélo smoothie ou encore ateliers
savoir rouler à vélo et puis c'est la
fin de ce journal merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi très bonne soirée sur télé
[Musique]